hey guys I'm Jess this is Dan and you're
watching games what news what what
what's happening what's wrong it's easy
on the whole planet okay well I mean
this is like a five-minute set you can
play up I'm part of now
seems excessive first up suda51 has been
dropping hints on what we can expect
from no more here is when it arrives on
Nintendo's which over the weekend Jul
shockers asked Sudha how he felt about
working on the switch and if no more
heroes Travis strikes again will remain
a switch exclusive in true suitor
fashion he described to Nintendo as by
far the most Punk hardware manufacturer
and that he's always loved developing
for Nintendo consoles and while he
regards the wait and GameCube as Punk
the switch is the most Punk wonderful if
you thought that confused the translator
well when asked if the new No More
Heroes would be a switch exclusive he
responded immediately with yes in
Japanese but then added maybe in English
in other No More Heroes news polygons
reported that multiplayer may be coming
to franchise sort of shared that the
team has made sure the game is fully
playable with only one joke on and when
asked about the second joke on he
responded we're going to be releasing
information at some point in the future
but as you can see there are two main
characters so draw your own conclusions
if you want
next up Resident Evil Stefan is getting
a gold edition along with free DLC later
this year I feel like I've been easily
break atlas nope Capcom today announced
the gold edition which contains old
previously released DLC and the upcoming
not a hero and end of Zowie add-ons
which launched on December 12th and of
Zoe will see you discovering what
happened to Zoe after the events of
Resident Evil 7 well no the hero stars
Chris Redfield as he tracks down in
elusive foe and of Zoe will be available
for purchase on all platforms and will
come as part of the Gold Edition while
not a hero will be free for all owners
of Resident Evil 7 both add-ons will
support PlayStation VR you can check out
the new trailer for the gold edition
over on GameSpot finally it looks like
Borderlands 3 might be coming there's
been no official confirmation but it
does look like it's on the horizon Keith
can I get these off now please developer
gearbox CEO Randy Pitchford told jewel
Shockers that around a ninety percent of
the company's production staff are quote
working on the thing I think most of you
guys want us to be working on so you
know hopefully it's Borderlands 3 and
not like aliens colonial Marines - maybe
it's the Wii U version of aliens
colonial Marines
pitchford was careful to add that this
isn't a guarantee as the product doesn't
exist until it's announced he confirmed
last year that a new Borderlands game
was in development but it won't
necessarily be called Borderlands 3
another clue came last month when
take-two interactive the parent company
of Borderlands developer 2k games said
that a highly anticipated new title from
one of two K's biggest franchises is due
out in fiscal 2019 which runs from April
2018 to March 2019 that's everything we
have for you today I'm gonna go play
destiny 2 now goodbye guess what wasn't
even taped to the back I move magic oh
so scary